[Music]
that's why you
hey everybody got a pedal down man my
[ __ ] thighs are burning
freak out a little bit rain
earnhardt passes for the win
[Music]
is
now we're kind of moving
[Music]
up
[Music]
that's my score y'all know who winning
back on my head little [ __ ] come get it
like
i put the fire on the stove i'll put the
range on the road spray the cologne
then i'm gonna walk to the door throw
that little [ __ ] baby i'm up right now
[Music]
my diet's already [ __ ] so it's like
once i start going downhill i
go all the way down you want ice cream i
know you look like you did i don't know
i want some ice cream yeah i don't
really see you right i want some ice
cream right there
we got going on tonight b two shows
tacoma comedy club hopefully no one
tries to break into the green room and
stab us again
other than that pretty excited about you
jay how many how many buffalo chases we
gonna have tonight
[Music]
up
[Music]
i don't know what
[Applause]
later
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been out here
the other day
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's my time to come i love you guys
[Applause]
get home safe stay thick